we must stay alert we must continue  to control the virus and save lives  and yet we must also recognize that this  campaign against the virus has come at  colossal cost to our way of life we can  see it all around us  in these shuttered shops and abandoned  businesses and darkened pubs  and restaurants and there are millions  of people  who are both fearful of this terrible  disease  and at the same time also fearful  of what this long period of enforced  inactivity  will do to their livelihoods and their  mental  and physical well-being to their futures  and the futures of their children  so i want to provide tonight for you  the shape of a plan to address both  fears  both to beat the virus and provide the  first sketch  of a road map for reopening society  a sense of the way ahead and when and  how  and on what basis  we will take the decisions to proceed  i'll be sending out more details in  parliament tomorrow  and taking questions from the public in  the evening